Uh LOOK, I, I was, I was going to
ask you because uh I think that in one
of our conversations, we talked a little bit about
this. But uh I was uh I was curious,
I got curious the other day, um when you're,
when you're in the process in the initial steps
of creating a story, uh o of course, I
don't want you to just leave on the table
all your cards, all of the things that you
use as a, as a writer. I'm an open
book but I'll talk about anything. But uh uh
uh how do you go about it exactly. I
mean, because of course, I imagine that different writers,
different artists have different methods, different processes. They go
through different creative ways of uh building up their
stories. But uh how do you do it exactly?
I mean, uh perhaps not so much how you
do it but uh how much of it do
you plan ahead? So you, uh for example, you
have an idea for a story before you start
writing. Do you already have a detailed plan about
uh the characters that you will have their, their
personalities, their names the places where the story will
take place, the ending or how do you go
about
it? I used to not, first of all, what
you're talking about is there are two kinds of
writers, they say plotters and panthers, plotters plot, right?
And panthers fly by the seat of their pants.
I used to be a panther and because I,
I felt like, I don't know, II, I like
that feeling of kind of winging it and seeing
where the story took me. And then I, um
I wrote an outline for one of my novels
and by outline, I didn't kind of, I didn't
really write a classical outline. In fact, I didn't
even start out trying to write an outline. I
was just trying to think through, I knew I
wanted to tell a certain story and I was
trying to think through how I would get from
one part of the story to the next. And
so what I began doing was um writing a
chapter, giving the chapter a name. I didn't always
give the chapter a name first. Sometimes I, I
wrote a short summary of it first. I would
just write a short summary, basically what I wanted
to happen in that chapter. And so that's how
I've settled on writing an outline that to, to
put it more into a narrative, you know, to
put my outline into a, into prose, you know,
into a, into an actual functioning narrative works better
for me than writing the, the sort of classical
outline of, you know, the chapter one a is
going to happen, the protagonist meets the heroine, they
go on a motorcycle ride, you know, that, that
doesn't work for me. It doesn't, it doesn't inspire
me sufficiently to wanna write to that direct, you
know, to that chapter. So, you know, sometimes if
I write a relatively short summary, that's maybe just
a paragraph. Other times, I even, you know, if
I feel moved, I'll write an entire scene from
that, you know, as it kind of comes to
me, not perfect obviously, but just maybe a few
lines of dialogue, whatever it is. And that has
been really helpful to me. So now I think
I'm an official plotter because I, um not only
does that expedite the process tremendously, it, it just
makes it so much easier to write. It also
keeps somebody like me who is prone to creative
tangents. It keeps me on the straight and narrow
and not, you know, taking the reader to a
place they don't need to go and they don't
even really want to go, which is, you know,
kind of important. You, you have to keep your
readers uh needs in mind. You know, I think
as a writer, I think that's important, not just
your own needs. It's, it's, it's a conversation you're
having in a sense with someone who is picking
up your work and, and, and and you have
to remember that it's not one sided.
Yeah. You know, I, I was curious about asking
you about that. O of course, again, you're just
one single creator. There are many different ways of
doing the same thing. I bet. So, but I,
I was just thinking so for example, we've already
talked here on the show about, for example, uh
a game of Thrones, I mentioned a few times
one piece and I mean, I was just uh
and the Lord of the Rings also, for example,
uh I was just thinking about uh when writers
try to go about creating those massive stories that
go for more than 1000 chapters in manga or
several different uh 1000 pages volumes uh book volumes.
I was just thinking, how much ahead do they
plan their story? Because sometimes the story flows so
well that one as a reader would think. Oh
OK. So this guy before he started his story,
he might have had uh II I don't know
1000 pages of detailed plot, plot lines or scenes
that he would go through and he must have
had everything planned from the start. But then you
get to, I don't know the latest or what
will be the latest book by George RR Martin
the Winds of winter. And he's been trying to
write it since 2011 and he's just like stuck
beca and, and then, and then when that something
like that happens when the writer goes for 12
years without being able to, to finish the sixth
book in the install the sixth installment in the
series. You're like, oh, ok. So wait a minute,
let's track back a little bit because this guy
hasn't planned that far ahead because now he doesn't
know what to do with so many plot lines
and with so many different things happening at the
same time in the story. And then, you know,
then sometimes readers read too much into something that
came previously in the story and, and then they
expect it to come back and a plot line
and, and it was never intended to be
that. Yeah. And, and, and sometimes it's just, oh
my God, these, these here two books ago was
foreshadowing or, and it's not foreshadowing at all. It
was just that they coincidentally uh brought to the
story, something that if you look back, it, it
seems that 200 chapters ago there was foreshadowing for
that, but it was not for shadowing at
all. I'll tell you when I look at someone
like George RR Martin, I'm sure that Game of
Thrones, the TV series was both a blessing and
a curse because something like that, it, it really
does interrupt your story process and you don't, you
don't want it to kind of absorb into your
vision for the story. But it does, I think
that um the same is probably true uh for,
for people who, um, for kind of established people
with an established voice in their writing if they
attempt to use a I for something more than
say an outline, um, because it's, it, it, it
begins to conflict with your own ideas, but it
gives you ideas at the same time, but then
you kind of lose sight of where you are.
And I think that, that probably, I can't imagine
that didn't have an effect on him to watch
them in my, you know, in our opinion, badly
finish up his series, right? And now there are
all these expectations and he's probably got to do,
you know, the double work of, for one of,
I'm sure his work was interrupted by the series
because he had to attend to that. But then
to extract himself from the conclusions that the series
writers made and also allow there to be perhaps
time enough for fans of the television series to
get unvested in the way that the series writers
um develop the characters and end of the story
so that they can invest in what Martin is
writing. Um That II, I mean, I can imagine
that's a huge challenge. I mean, II, I know
a lot of people are so mad at him
for not having come out with um with this
latest uh you know, installment of Game of Thrones,
but I completely understand it and I, I think
he's probably doing the right thing, taking his time
about it because unless he was just so in
the zone and could finish it, despite the fact
that he had this Blockbuster series going on, which,
I mean, unless you're a hermit of a writer,
how can you not be affected by that? Um,
I think probably the more time he gives it
the more, um, hopefully, you know, readers will be
willing to reinvest in his, uh, in his vision
for the story. I suspect he's gonna end it
quite differently than the way it ended, don't you?
I
hope so. I really
do. I mean, I, I really don't see it
going any other way. Um, BECAUSE I mean, the
way they ended, it was just so mind bogglingly
television for God's sake, you know, I mean, it
was just so it was so
amateur AAA and you know what I like is,
uh, when sometimes writers are really honest about how
they do things and how things work because I've
watched a few months ago an interview with George
Rrrr Martin and, uh, uh, the interviewers were asking
him. Oh, so you've, uh, did you, have you
seen that, um, that theory, uh, uh that was
made by fans that's, uh, going around, uh, in
the, on the internet about this or that, or
is something that happened in the book? The, uh
does it have this or that meaning? And he
was like, and he was like, look, you can
do with my story, whatever you want, it doesn't
bother me. But people are sometimes read too much
into your own work. It's not that complex. The
only thing I have in mind there was this
simple thing. It's not like connecting 1000 different points
in the story. It's nothing like that. It was
as simple as this. And so, and he also
says that there are things for example, but his
characters, for example, the color of someone's eyes or
particular aspects of their personality or particular things that
he mentions in the main story, but are, are
not part of the main story. I mean, some
of the background story to a Game of Thrones,
for example, that he actually has to go and
ask other experts on his own books because he
doesn't remember anymore.
Ricardo. It's so true because I mean, I, you
know, I, I write in usually in series form,
at least like a loose series of, of, of,
you know, books, there might be a series of
books that are in the same universe and my
kids are always kind of laughing at me because
they'll see me like rereading my own books and
they're like, why are you reading your own book?
You know, like, because I don't remember what I
wrote and I have to make sure that I
have continuity. So I'm sitting there reading my own
books, you know, taking notes going, oh my God,
I completely forgot that I wrote that you know,
because you, do, you forget it the way you
forget things in your own life and, you know,
a friend might be like, don't you remember when
we did Xy and Z and you're like, no,
I don't remember that at all. When did that
happen? You know, and, and you know, to them,
it was obviously kind of an, in a fairly
important experience, at least enough for them to remember
what happened and you're looking at them like, II,
I got nothing, you know what I mean?
But, but, but it is,
it's incredibly detailed work writing a series and, you
know, unless the series is, is very simple, you
know, and, and, but um ok, there's just a
lot going on, you're writing somebody's life and sometimes
the lives of multiple characters and it can, it
can, you can easily misremember what happened in your
own story the same way you can, you can,
uh you know, have a false memory about something
in your own life and um interpret a whole
series of events differently because you remember it differently
than other people who are experiencing it.
Yeah. But, but that's the thing because we, because
there are people who are able to create such
good stories. We sort of tend to idolize them
and think of them as being people who died
with, I don't know, 200 IQ and perfect memories
and a big planners and they, they, and, and
like they are the, the, your book in their
head from the very beginning. But actually, uh, uh,
uh, I, I mean, I've never wrote a book
but I would imagine that perhaps most of the
time you're actually rereading and rewriting,
for sure. I'm doing something right now that I've
never done before. Um, I'm writing a Cold War
Detective. No, our series, but I'm gonna finish the
first. Uh, WELL, I'm gonna call it a season.
It may never have more than one season, but
I'm kind of using television language for this because
it, it, it seems appropriate for the way I'm
structuring it. I, I want to finish the entire
first season which will be several books, not like
super thick books, like my breath series is thick.
It's, you know, it's historical fantasy. So they're like,
you know, 450 pages, whatever. Each, these are barely
not, you know, they're, they're novels but they're Detective
Noir. And so they're more in the style, you
know, well, obviously more in the style of, but
also, you know, it's more of what you would
expect from. Um, YOU know, Dashiell Hammett and other
noir writers. Um, BUT I, what I'm gonna be
interested to find out is if I prefer writing
the books, one at a time being able to
sit on them for a while, think about it,
then write the next book or to essentially write
it like, you know, one big story, one big
book um, but all at once, basically, you know
what I mean? All at once, write all these
books at once. And, um, you know, my intention
is, you know, I'm, I'm doing a little experiment
here. My intention is to, uh release them quickly
and sequentially because I'd like to see how that
works. You know, I'd like to see if, um,
if, uh, it becomes more, you know, if, if
it becomes in inspiring motivating for a reader to
just, you know, go through the entire series at
once this way with you kind of in real
time as they're being, um as they're being introduced
and launched. I'm, I'm rereading this, this book right
now and I'm really just at the very beginning,
but I'm, I'm, I'm enjoying the experience a lot.
It's called The Artist's Way by Julia Cameron. I
mean, it's like 30 years old. She was an
ex-wife of Martin Scorsese and she's, she's kind of
made, she's a writer too, but she also made
a second career basically out of um unlocking people's
creativity. Yeah, kind of this, this sort of motivational
style teacher. But um it, and, but somehow this
was a book I never ended up reading, like,
I, I love books, like Writing Down The Bones
by um Natalie Goldberg. But um I, I'd never
read the Artist's Way. And even though it's, it's
probably the most, um it, it, it's the kind
of book that I would most relate to because
it does kind of take this, this spiritual approach
to creativity and, and, and, um that's something that's,
you know, very much part of my personality makeup.
But it, it kind of takes you through the
process of sitting with a story and, and being
in a place where you can eavesdrop on the
characters, which, uh you know, a lot of it's
that it's easy to get out of that place
and to put a lot of pressure on yourself
and be like, oh my God. Now I've got
to write this and I think that when you
stop eavesdropping on your characters, you start putting, um,
kind of undue, focus on maybe the setting and
you can write, you know, three pages of expo
exposition, just sort of describing where people are and
you don't need three pages of that. You know,
it's, it's usually not always. But, um, you know,
you can really become tiresome for a reader if
you're not, um, in the zone, if that makes
sense, you know, if you're not in a, in
a place where you're able to listen. Yeah. And
I think being in that place where you're able
to listen makes it, um, will make, it, makes
it a lot more likely that, uh, you're also
listening to the needs of the reader, not just
to your own needs. Mhm. But anyway, so I,
I'm, I've started on this and I'm trying to
get up earlier in the morning. And read it
before I start work rather than reading at night,
which is my usual, um, mo, uh, because I
just get so tired at night that I really
can't make it past a couple of pages anyway
and I just fall right, right asleep. Um, BUT
it's interesting and it's, it's also, I started reading
it because I, um, I, I've started book coaching
someone, a friend of mine who's wanted to write,
uh who's a very good writer and a creative
person, but who has never written a novel and
has, and wants to write a series, which the
idea for her series is just terrific. So I'm
really excited about it. It's been a lot of
fun coaching her and, you know, I've kind of
book, coached people in piecemeal throughout the years, but
it's something that I've never really wanted to commit
to, um for one because I have three kids
at home and you really, you can only do
so much. But it's, it's, you know, it, it
sort of came at the right time because I'm
trying to write this series, you know, which is
very different from, it's very different from the way
I usually write. And so I'm, it, it's also
forcing me to take my own advice and to
follow that. Um So that's that, I don't know
where else to go with that. But, um, oh,
ok. So le let me put, let me put
a pin on that book coaching thing because I
want to get back to that. I don't know
if to, if today or next time. Let's see,
because I, because I have a particular uh interesting,
let's say thought experiment to ask you about that
thought experiments. We always talk about thought experiments when
we get together. It's great.
Yeah. But, but le let me ask you this,
uh are there times where you get a little
bit frustrated about what you think are perhaps some
of the limitations of your medium? There is limitations
of being a writer instead of being, for example,
uh Mange or someone who creates uh comics or
uh a film director. Just because for example, in
those particular cases, they have visual aid to the
story, right? I mean, are, are there times where
you, where you think? Oh my God, if I
was doing a movie instead of a book or
if I was doing a comic instead of a
book, this would be so much easier to portray
or I, I mean, I'm not trying to ask
you here, of course, but I'm not, I'm not
trying to imply that that uh a book is
better or worse than cinema or comics or whatever.
It's just that perhaps you think that there are
particular things, particular aspects that you think that perhaps
are better than or portrayed in mediums where you
have a visual aspect to them. For example,
I, I think that is, yes, I mean, the,
the short answer is yes, I, you know, I,
you can almost see that at play in any
medium. You can see where uh on occasion, at
least where um the creator had to invent a
device. Maybe it's a narrator, you know, who, who
in a film, you know, who kind of talks
over what's going on. Um Because they, they simply
weren't able to adequately tell the story without that.
And for sure, there are times because I'm a
really visual person. I love film, you know, II,
I enjoy film as much as I enjoy reading
a really juicy novel. Um So there are many
times when I'm writing something and I really have
to stop and think because I'm trying to um
explain something that's very visual and yet I don't
want to do it in a way that bores
or exhaust the reader. And I'm, you know, I'm
sure that that's the case and for someone, you
know, creating manga or, um you know, comic books,
comic books, you know, it's not like in most
cases, you can have someone do a monologue that's
this long, you know, I mean, you have to
have a very crisp, it's kind of like tweeting,
you know.
Well, well, actually, actually it's nice but, but actually
it's also interesting because there are many different kinds
of styles for comic books and manga because there
are um some creators that let's put it this
way, they are very verbose. So sometimes you get
almost walls of text and you are like, oh
come on, it's, you know, to
me, then you lose the visual and the whole
point is the visual. It's the play between the
words in the bubble, right? But
some of those creators are actually very good and
sometimes that sort of wall of text is needed
or warranted. But, but, but there are others and
again, I'm not saying that one way is better
than the other. It's uh whatever you prefer. But
there are others that they almost do not have
any text at all. It's the, they are so
good with uh telling you a story just through
images that they uh they just need one word
here or there. Sometimes they even o on a
single page, they occupy it with an image and
then one single vertical wor word or something like
that and it's enough. So, you know, it, it
is, it's, it's amazing how uh the many different
ways there are for people to create great stories,
I guess
there, there are and they're infinite, aren't they? And,
and it just sort of depends on um on,
on the way on the creators approach and what
their, what their own skills are. No, you know,
some are, it's amazing when you read some books
that are so dialogue heavy and yet they don't
feel that way because, you know, reading just a
bunch of dialogue can without any descriptors, you know,
without anything in between that tells you where they
are or, you know, how a character, a little
movement that a character might have made that, that
lets you know what exactly they're trying to say.
E even though, you know, they might be talking
about the weather but really they're talking about something
else underneath and, and, you know, that just because
of, you know, a look, they give someone, you,
you know what?
It's incredible to be able to do that without
that, you know, without those, that those descriptors, you
know, and just to do it through dialogue. And
then on the other hand, you have other people
who will have almost no dialogue at all, which
can also be dreary and yet are able to
communicate a scene, a party, a cocktail party where
everybody is talking, you know, without hardly a single
word of dialogue and yet it's incredible, you
know, OK, so I'm going to give you two
different examples. So, uh first of all, I'm uh
a sucker for a good dialogue story. I love,
I love dialogue. I mean, even in movies, one
of the things, one of the criteria that I
use to classify a movie as good is it
has good dialogue. OK. So for me, it's almost
all of what
makes, makes me wanna throw rotten tomatoes.
But, but there's, there's a movie, I don't know
if you ever watch it, watched it. Uh My
dinner with Andre.
Oh, yes. Oh my
God. Look, there's the visual aid there for sure,
because it's a movie. But still, it's one of
my favorite movies and it's just, it's as simple
as you can get. It's like two guys, two
guys
having dinner and,
and, and having A&E long conversation about anything and
everything. And I really love that movie and, and
then on the others on the other side, uh
there's a Portuguese writer from the 19th century called
S Kos. And uh he's magnum opus or at
least the book that people consider his magnum opus.
It's even mandatory reading here in Portuguese schools is
uh the Mayas in English and Portuguese Mayas. But
anyway, and he, he is, he was a realist
writer. I mean, realism from the 19th century where
many times some of those writers were really heavy
when it comes to description, I mean, sin, description
and describing places and all of that. And I
mean, I love the story, but I have to
be honest whenever it gets to the descriptions, I
have to skip them because it's just too much.
I mean, he describes every single object in the
room and I'm like, oh, come on, man.
Well, yeah, you have to. II I feel at
least, yeah, I mean, I guess you don't have
to but um I, I feel like you want
to leave something to the imagination of the reader
for them to fill in you know, you want
to sketch it for sure. And you want to
give them a little color here and there. But
that makes it the reader's own too. That's how,
you know, readers feel a sense of um investment
in a look about to use their imaginations
too and about the descriptions. I don't know if
you agree with me on this or not, but
the descriptions I like the most are the ones
where you are describing relevant things to the story.
So I don't know, let's think about the concept
of uh Chekhov's gun. OK. So you're describing the
gun but the gun, the gun gets used but
you, but just describing all the chairs, the tables
are, these are that way and then it doesn't
matter at all to the plot because you're not
going to use the chair or the table or
the call or whatever, or the chandelier or whatever.
I, I mean, it's just too much for me
if you're describing things that do not. I, I
mean, I understand that descriptions might also not be
used useful for the plot itself. It's, it's just
describing a beautiful scenery or a beautiful house or
I, I understand that people might like that, but
for me, it's just uh I, I don't know,
it breaks the pace of the story, you know,
I
don't like excessive description and I, I think I've,
I think I've committed that sin as a writer
by the way. And um often I'll just speak
for myself. It, it, that, that needs to be
taken out, I think during the editorial process because
I think sometimes when you're writing a story and
you're listening and on that story, um you know,
you're, you're building the environment in your own mind.
If you haven't, if you're not the kind of
person who builds it excessively on the front end,
which I don't do. I, I feel like I
find that inhibiting and, and then you're always at
least I am not you. But then I'm always
checking to see what was it that I said
needs to be in that. Oh, well, I guess
I should write that in and that interrupts my
flow. Um But for sure. And then, then what
you're faced with sometimes most of the time is
that at least in some parts of your story
you've over described because you, you know, you get
into a room and you're like, well, where, what
is this room? And then you, you know, you,
you describe it and sometimes you might even describe
it really, really well and you've got to make
the decision then and not be vain about it
for heaven's sake and say, OK, that's a great
paragraph. But it's got to go or it's got
to be cut by two thirds because who cares?
You know what I mean? It's inhibiting and it's,
it's clunky. It's, you know, you, you, you, you
not enhancing the experience of the
reader and look again again, people who like that
kind of thing perfectly, perfectly fine. I, I, I'm
not bothered by that at all, but hi myself,
I'm, I'm a character and plot guy characters and
plots are the, the, the two most important things
for me. I mean, you can even be uh,
extremely bad at describing places and it doesn't matter
much to me as long as the, the characters
are well developed and the plot is interesting.
II, I agree. I love character driven stories. They're
my favorite. I like a good plot. You know,
I've been, I, I want there to be a
plot, um, with the characters but those are the
two most important things to me. And I think
that, you know, like some readers, you know, the
sort of, um, you know, the, the Dan Brown
stories, for instance, those, those are great. They plot
their plot, plot, plot, plot, plot. Um, IT'S, they're
for people who love puzzles. Yeah. And a lot
of mysteries are that way, you know? Exactly. Not
exactly how they're going to end. You may not
know exactly who did it but you, you know
the procedure through the story and it's, it's, it
really is like playing a game, um, a board
game or doing, uh, doing some kind of, um,
word puzzle, a crossword puzzle or whatnot. And I,
I like a little more than that. It's kind
of, you know, why I like, uh, mystery writers.
Like, um, well, I feel like PD James does
a really great job that she, she creates a
world and it's not just a puzzle.
Oh, no. Look, II, I definitely think that, I
think that the crime stories are some of the
best ones out there to explore human psychology. For
sure, for sure. And that's why I love to
read. I like to explore human psychology. I like
to be the person sitting there, you know, watching
people go by. I like watching my own behavior.
Um And as you know, and I like to
be as detached about it as possible and, you
know, understand my own motives in a, in a
kind of clear eyed way. And I like to
do that with others. It's um I, I just
find that to be really, really interesting and, but,
but the, the then Brown books look, I, I
know that perhaps I will be crucified by some
intellectual people. But I actually like Dan Brown. I
do. No, no, no, I, I was, I, that
wasn't a criticism of Dan. No, no, no. I
think I'm saying it's a certain style of writing
that is, that's plot focused and hugely addictive because
it's a puzzle and it's primarily a puzzle. It's
not that um his characters aren't, aren't interesting, but
that's not the focus of the book. Um What
is it, the character in it is in Robert
Langdon? I think the professor really interesting concept for
a character, but the character doesn't get developed in
any massive, you know, or, or deep way. It's
about the puzzle. And, um you know,
uh but, but by the, by the way, since,
since you touch there on character development, I also
wanted to ask you this. So because people, uh
I, I mean, at least the more critical kind
of people, they tend to uh talk a lot
about uh developing and liking a multi-layered characters that
is characters that are not just one dimensional and
that are psychologically complex. And I mean, uh but
what does that mean? Exactly? Because uh sometimes, so
ju just to, I, I mean, run through a
sort of abstract example, but sometimes people complain about
characters being one dimensional. But then uh on the
other hand, sometimes people also complain about characters breaking
character and, and sometimes it seems a bit weird
to me because not always, but some of those
times what people are referring to is, oh, so
this character did something in this particular situation or
uh behaved toward another character in a way that
doesn't uh doesn't go along with the kind of
expectations you have for him. But I, isn't it
a bit weird because we ourselves in our, let's
say real lives, we don't behave the same way
with everyone, right? I mean, I mean, I, I
mean, we, we have, we behave differently depending on
the person we, we are interacting with and the
kind of relationship we have with them. Right. So,
so what I'm trying to say is, oh, I
don't know. Let's say that someone, um, I know,
let's say that you're talking about Tony Soprano and
he is a criminal and he's a very tough
guy or, I mean, apparently tough guy. Uh, AND,
uh, uh, and then, uh, suddenly he's a guy
who can't really hurt Children and animals and all
of that. I, I mean, people, perhaps, sometimes people
are expecting for a criminal to be a psychopath
and to be bad to everyone around him. But
that doesn't need to be the case necessarily. No,
they can be, um, they can act in, you
know, what can be viewed as a psychopathic matter
under very certain circumstances. I think, um, terrorists are
a great example who might themselves have, you know,
completely normal family lives if you went home and
have a wife and Children, whatever it is. Um,
AND then under a very particular circumstance they're capable
of doing horrendous. Thanks.
Yeah. Um, BUT, but
like with war, you know, that's something that happens
a lot more common under, under really intense circumstances
like that. It's something that, you know, a soldier
has to contend with. It's something that someone who
is, you know, in an occupied land or is,
you know, an aggressor has to contend with all
of this, even if they think that they have
every right to be doing what they're doing.
But, but, you know, now that I've described that
to you, that sort of, uh, I don't know,
contradictory or conflicting view that people have of characters
where they expect them to be one thing, but
at the same time, they want them to be
multi layered. And so, I mean, and now now
that I have described that to you, it came
to my mind that perhaps the way people react
or think react to or think about characters is
the same way we think about real people because
we expect people to be, let's say a good
person or a bad person every time toward everyone
in every situation. But sometimes people are just different
people in different situations, they behave differently to different
kinds of people and sometimes people are behaving unexpected
ways as well.
It's true, human beings are predictable only for kind
of it for short spurts. You know, you might
be able to predict if you, you know what
I'm saying, you might be able to predict um
the way a conversation will go in the first
few minutes because you're exchanging pleasantries. Not always, but,
you know, sometimes the conversation starts off and it's,
you know, it starts off in a completely different
place than you never expected. But, you know, you
can pretty much predict when you run into someone
on the street that you haven't seen in a
while that, oh, nice to see you Ricardo. How
are you? I'm doing well. Can you believe this
weather? No, I can't. Sure it is hot for
this time of year. You know, you can predict
it until a certain point and then you have
no idea. If you actually sit down with this
person and you don't, you know, go your separate
ways, you have no idea really where that conversation
is going to go. Um, BUT II, I, I
think when two things happen, when someone says, oh,
I, I didn't like that because that character wouldn't
do that. Um Either it's because the writer failed.
They did not, um, at least at that point
have the skill to help take you on that
character's journey and show you how the character, um,
you know, kind of build the latter rungs between
this behavior over here and then this seemingly out
of character behavior over here. Um It could be
because of the, uh, reader's expectation that, hey, I
wanted a happy ending. I thought those two were
gonna end up together, you know what I mean
or whatever, you know, and, and their expectation kind
of superseded, maybe what was organic to the story
in their own mind, at least. And, um, so
they, they could not accept the story that the
writer actually wrote because they wanted. This is what
I wanted. I mean, you, I, I think you
and I have talked about um, certain genres like
the romance genre, for instance, that um, a book
is not a romance and unless it has a
happy ending then it's not a romance that it's
a love story. If it has a, you know,
a different ending other than, and they lived happily
ever after or they lived happily ever after for
now, you know what I mean? Um, AND so,
uh, you know, you, a writer has to be
very careful depending on the genre that they're writing
in. Because if you are writing a, a AAA
piece that is pretty strictly adhering to genre, you're
setting up very specific expectations for the reader. And
if you deny the reader what they're expecting, um
you'll be punished for it. Now, if the reader
is expecting something that's genre bending from the get
go, they'll usually go on that journey with you
if they like your writing, you know, assuming that
they actually like what you have to say and
um and they'll enjoy being taken on that journey
and they'll say, oh my gosh, can you believe
that this happened? Um And, but it, it, it,
it does a lot of, it depends on expectation.
And I, I think also, I think a, a
writer or creator has to be careful not to
um not to make a character, do something or
create a situation just for the sake of creating
it because they want to do something different or
because they want to make a, a political point,
you know, it's, or or, or a personal point,
you know, it, it, that's kind of where the
artistry comes from is understanding what is outside of
what you're creating, what is organic to the story
that you've set up and you've perhaps, you know,
written the bones off. But the, the fact is
there's something else going on besides, um, besides your,
you know, your expectations, your original expectations for the
story. I mean, I can't tell you how many
times I started to write something and then, and
I've even had it, you know, plotted out and
everything. And then I realize at some point in
the story that something has to change because I
start to recognize and this can be really painful
by the way because it can undo a lot
of work you've already done or it can just
hurt because you, you're realizing that something really painful
has to happen in this story and, and writing
that is painful. You know, if you have to
kill a character for instance, that you've become really
attached to and you're realizing, oh my God, this
person can't survive this. I didn't realize that when
I was writing it. You know, I thought this
person was gonna survive. I thought this person was
gonna go on and, and do you know the
things that I had prescribed for them? But I'm
realizing right now that they're about to get it
in the neck.
Yeah. No. No. About the ex the expectations So
several ideas. So one of them is you really
get to have direct contact with how different expectations
make people love or hate stories. When there's an
ongoing story. And you go, for example, to online
forums and people are trying to uh trying to
imagine what we like happen next in the story.
And then there are people that say, oh the
X should happen. And then there are people that
say, why should happen. And there are people that
say, oh wherever, wherever uh let's see what happens
and then we'll see if it's good or not.
And when the uh for example, people who got
it right? Usually like the story, people who got
it wrong usually. Yeah. And then the ones that
were just open to see where things would go.
I mean, most of the time, if they already
like the story, they keep liking it sometimes it's
just, oh, this was a bit silly. Uh And
then also you mentioned uh politics at a certain
point there. And I was thinking like, ee even
politics, sometimes, even if a book is heavily political,
sometimes it works. So it just, just think about
Ayn Rand's Atlas Rugged. I, I mean, for me,
that book is awful, but Libertarians, they love the
book. It's like, it's like the best book
ever. Conde's books are I think, beautiful and they're,
I think he was absolutely robbed of the Nobel
in literature, but they're highly political. You know, um,
I don't think it's ever, I, I think that
the, the story is at the forefront and the
story is so compelling which is what makes it,
um, which is what makes it so good. You
know, even though he has a very clear political
point of view, I mean, it's kind of impossible
to miss but, and, and it's interesting because what
I, I read it's just the opposite. Her politics
are fascinating. You know what I mean? And, you
know, her characters aren't that great. The story is
interesting. I think the plots are pretty interesting but
the characters aren't that great but her, but she
is, she is such a force. She is so
interesting that, like, like you said, particularly libertarians, particularly
if you are, um, you know, highly susceptible to
that point of view. It's riveting for you the
way, you know, happily ever after is the only
acceptable outcome for someone who is a true lover
of romance.
Yeah. And, and the same for the same for
people on the left. I don't know if, you
know Berthold Brecht or a writer from the, I
think the late 19th century. And, I mean, his
book
I haven't read.
Yeah, he, his books, his books are like a
cheesecake for leftists. It's, it's just, it's just like
bashing the powerful uplifting the Van Dren. Yeah. But,
and I mean, the books are ob, uh, objectively
speaking, not that great, but for someone who is
just for someone who, who, you know, wants to
experience that. Right. Yeah.
And then uh just going back to the character
for a second. Uh Also there are particular kinds
of uh stories or fiction where a sort of
one dimensional characters work pretty well and work best.
So for example, Mr Bean, the, the comedy series,
I mean, I mean, Mr Bin is the simplest
character, you can create the, the thing there is
about creating funny situations. It's not really about the
character being extremely complex. It's a very simple character,
but it's a great comedy series, right?
No, it's true. And that's, that's kind of WW
well, you know, that goes back to, to whatever
the particular strengths of the writer are because there
are people who are incredibly good at creating circumstances
that force the characters to react to the circumstances
and then others do the inverse where the creator
or the creators, where the characters influence the circumstances
and all you wanna do is is follow that
character around and you know, watch them influence their
environment to watch other people react to them, other
characters react to them, watch how an organization might
change by the addition of this person, you know,
or um God, what is it that there's a
great um what is it called? Oh God, I'm
not going to bore you with it then because
if I can't recall it, I'm not gonna sit
here going now. What was that. But the story
was basically about um a bureaucrat who likes things
to be the absolute same all the time. It's
an old Thurber story, James Thurber I believe, and
a woman is hired into this company to make
changes as his boss. And that is very bad
for this guy. He does not like change. And
so he goes about orchestrating her demise, you know,
I mean, not her literal demise but her demise
in the company. And it's just, it's just so
funny. Oh my God, the only story that I
can think of where those two things play together
in this sort of like Escher like way. You
know,
now let me just say and you're probably going
to laugh at this. But uh when you describe
the character uh uh as being uh a guy
who wanted for uh things to be always the
same way. It, it, it this is for you
to uh to try to see, to have a
glimpse at how my mind works. What came to
my mind, someone who has, who likes to have
control over everything around them. And then the two
stories that came to my mind, Citizen Kane and
50 shades of Gray. I
got two stories that can possibly be more different,
right?
But this is just for you to see how
my mind works.
I think that's a good line.
Oh my God, this would probably make for a,
a good uh stand up plot.
So I was thinking about Citizen Kane and 50
shades of gray came to mind.
Yeah. Rosebud has everything to do with B Ds
M for sure. Yeah. Oh my
God. You know, the, the, I hope I haven't
mentioned this on one of our conversations because I
think we did talk about 50 shades of grey
at one point. But I, I thought the most
interesting thing about the 50 shades of grey phenomenon
came out of the prison system. Oh, really? Yes.
Um, I read this, this was back when, like,
this was back when 50 shades of grey was
kind of first out and it was first a
huge phenomenon and everybody was reading it. And, um,
the, the article that I was reading, the writer
focused on the fact that in men's prisons it
was number one, what men were reading in prisons
and in women's prisons, it, it didn't even crack
the top 10, maybe not even the top 20
which is sort of the opposite of what was
happening outside of prison. Right. And as I was
reading it, I was thinking, well, that makes sense
because those women are in prison probably because they
killed the son of a bitch just like this
guy. You know what I mean? They're used to
being treated that way and they don't glamorize it,
you know, they're like, you know what, when I
look at Christian Gray, I think, Mark or whatever,
you know? And, but I just thought that was
so interesting that, um, that, you know, women in
prison weren't reading it that they had, they, they
weren't interested in
it. But, you know,
the men were definitely reading 50 shades of gray.
But,
but, you know, may maybe the minority of prison
women or prisoners, female prisoners that were reading 50
shades of gray were the ones that those kinds
of people where they, uh, like to get angry
at the story. Oh, come on, I will keep
reading or watching this because this is making me
angry.
It's true. And it's, it's funny because there's this
one, uh review that went, you know, viral on
goodreads of 50 shades of gray. That was so
funny. I mean, it was like crying funny, laugh
out loud, funny. Um, AND she was a hater,
you know, she, she and her brother were reading
it out loud to each other hating on it.
And, you know, haters can just be so funny
though sometimes. So it was just, it was really,
really good. Um, YOU know, speaking of haters, I,
when we were talking about, um, stories that go
kind of that, that perhaps betray readers expectations or
defy readers' expectations, I was thinking about, um, the
Star Wars Universe and I'm, I don't know if
you're a Star Wars fan. I am not well
versed in this. I saw the first three, you
know, the ones that came out in the seventies
and I love them as a kid, but I
did not, I have not followed the series since
then, since then. But what has been interesting to
me is how angry Star Wars fans are at
Disney for how they, you know, took, I apparently
took the story sideways and, um, did not, uh
give readers what they were or readers, readers watchers,
um, what they were hoping for.
And it's also, it's also funny because if you
go on the internet, sometimes there's ongoing wars between
different fandoms and, and then, and then people vote
on what's the most toxic phantom out. It's, it's
like, oh my God, the Harry Potter fans versus
the Lord of the Rings fans and the Star
Wars fans versus the, the Star Trek fans and
the other sci-fi universes. And then it's George RR
Martin versus Tolkien versus whoever. And it's, it's
such, it's a trail.
Yeah. So, uh le let me ask you another
kind of question that I think is it's something
that even over this is our 6th, 5th or
sixth conversation. I lost count by knowledge. But all
I know is that I now like need glasses
to see you clearly. Well, not when I, when
I'm, when I sit back and I didn't when
we first started. How's that?
Well, I also have some white hairs on my
beard now and five years ago. Yeah.
Well, they're a little blurry to me so I
don't see them I just see a nice lush.
Yeah, probably on camera. It's hard to see them
but I it, it's very easy to notice them
in, in person. Anyway. Are there any things when
you're writing a story that you just think to
yourself? Ok. So I would never go there. There
is for example, describing the very tiniest details of
a crime or I don't know, exploring topics that
you think are uh too immoral to explore in
a story or perhaps creating characters that have specific
idea is that you, that you think are too
immoral. I mean, do, do you set any moral
limits to what you would explore in the story
or
not? Not that I know of because I think
that it's, it's about, you know, how, how that
is done. I mean, I don't, I, I can't
imagine ever writing something that genuinely glorify something grotesque
and doing it in a way that is, you
know, obviously an endorsement, let's put it that way.
You know what I mean? Excuse me, I, all
allergies are upon me but II, I can't think
of anything that I absolutely wouldn't address. I always
thought that I couldn't address a child being hurt,
uh especially being a mother. That's really difficult. I
mean, it is really, really difficult. It's, you know,
in the same way that it's, uh, it's also
hard for me like to watch an, you know,
a dog being hurt, you know, an animal being
hurt in that way, but I did address it
in a book and that kind of surprised me
and I, and I did it because I realized
that I'd set up the story in such a
way that I had to address it. I couldn't
leave it. I didn't get into, um, I didn't,
you know, I didn't make a meal of it.
Um, AND not that maybe that III I, I'm
not saying that it would be bad to do
that in all circumstances, but that's just not something
that I wanted to do at all. But I
realized that I did have to address it because,
um, it was a sit, it was a war
situation and a child was, excuse me, I'm sorry.
And the child was killed. And, um, and it
was in a, in a, a pretty awful way
and by a pretty awful person. But, um, but
I felt like I, I was shirking a responsibility
to the reader if I didn't address that, um,
the reader was invested in this story, was invested
in the child. And also it was necessary for
the development of another character, for that to happen
to them, you know, and for, I, I had
to create a circumstance that was awful enough that
it would propel the story to where it needed
to go if that makes sense. Um, SO, and
I, not for any moral reason, I don't think
it's, it's ne it's necessarily immoral to um, depict,
uh, you know, a, a child being hurt or
killed. I think that it de depends entirely upon
context. But I never thought that I would write
it because I thought it would just be too
difficult and it was very difficult to write for
me. I avoided it for days because I knew
I had to write that scene and I, you
know, oh, I'll do some admin today. Well, I,
I have to write, um, um, I'll write an
essay on Family Law, you know, whatever it is.
I, I really, I avoided it in a pretty
egregious way for several days until I finally sat
down and said this is ridiculous. This has to
get written and I'm gonna do it and it
was such a relief to get it done. It's
hard. I mean, it's very hard to write certain,
yeah. Uh, TO write about certain topics and scenes.
I mean, it, it is really hard.
Ok. So let, let me ask you then another
question related to that. Have you ever read or
watched something fictional? Of course, where you fought? O
ok. So the author, the author here went too
far. I mean, this is just too graphic, too
detailed, too violent. Have you ever, ever, has anything
like that ever happened to you? No,
not in something I've read. But there is, this
a long time ago, there is a book that
I read, which was a sequel. It was the
sequel to, um, was the book Hannibal, it was
the sequel to Silence of The Lambs. But the
book version where I read it and I thought,
what the hell is this? Do you know what
I mean? Um So, you know, it, I, I
really felt like I felt like the author had
gone off the rails and was writing like a
weird fantasy of theirs and not, what was this?
Not the story that he had originally written book,
it's his story. So, just by definition, I'm wrong,
right? But as, as a reader, I felt like
he did not, um, that I felt like he'd
gone off the rails and not in a grotesque
sort of way. Not like, oh, I don't want
to read that but, you know what the hell
kind of way. But no, I've never read anything
that I can remember that. Um, THAT I couldn't
get through. I think often if you are absorbed
enough in a story, well, one of two things
can happen. You might love a character so much
that you're like, oh my God, I know they're
gonna die and I can't read that. You know,
you, you, you skip ahead a few pages, you
know what happened, you accept it but you just,
you just can't go there. I understand that. But
usually in what I'm reading, um, when I'm absorbed
enough in a story, I can take it and
I can understand why the author put it there
in the first place and why, um why I
have to be taken through that in order to,
you know, get to the other side, you know,
the other part of the story kind of like
what I described with what I felt like I
had when I had to put in, you know,
a difficult scene about a child being killed. Um
I, I put it there because I really didn't
see any other way for the story to evolve,
you know, to, to the, for the story to
get to the place that it needed to be.
And usually when I'm reading something II, I feel
that as well that doesn't mean that there aren't
parts of stories that I haven't read where I've
winced. I mean, really what comes to mind that
was so difficult to face was, um, Styron Sophie's
Choice. Mhm. I don't know if you've read Sophie's
Choice or if you've seen the movie.
No, I, that one particularly, I don't think so.
No.
But, ii, I mean, the story about a woman
named Sophie who, um, ends up in, during World
War Two in a concentration camp and they make,
she has two Children and they make her choose
which one is going to be killed. Mm. Hence
the title, I think they both end up being
killed. Um, BUT, you know, they do, they both
end up being killed but they make her choose
which is, you can, I mean, for a mother
that is like, it is so horrific to imagine
yourself in that situation that you wanna look away
because it's like, and III, I don't, I don't
even know. I don't, I mean, it would, it
would be hard for me to imagine uh, a
woman being able to write it. Not because she
wouldn't have the skill, but it's, you would almost
need that the detachment of a man to write
that. Not that a man is detached from his
Children. That's not what I mean. But it is
just, I mean, I can tell you as a,
as a parent, it's so like, mm, it's a
whole body experience. Um I can still like, II,
I can still physically conjure the um the, the
feeling that I would get when my child was
hungry. Yeah. And again, I mean, ii, I certainly
think a woman could write that. I'm not saying
that she couldn't. But uh uh I mean, thyroid
just did it so, so brilliantly, you know, and
that was fascinating and tragic and horrifying and beautiful.
OK. So
let me try to put it another way and
then perhaps I can give a few examples of
mine. Are there any stories in books, movies or
any other kind of medium that you've read, watched?
And uh after the fact you thought to yourself,
OK. So even if this is a great story
because of the way things are depicted, I don't
feel uh is recommending, recommending it to other people.
Have you ever had something like that or? I've,
I've, I'm not sure I put it quite that
way. Like, I mean, there's certainly stories where I
disagreed with the premise, maybe with their historical premise
or with a moral ambiguity that, um, that, that
the story, um, depicted, you know, I definitely, but
I would never, I don't think there, that I
would ever go so far as to say, um,
well, don't read that because of it where I
wouldn't recommend it. I'd, I'd say, well, it's interesting
but here's what I think, you know. Um I,
so I guess I don't, my answer is, I
don't think so. I can't, I can't conjure something,
you know, a memory of a time when I've,
when I've read something and said I'm so offended
by this. I think it shouldn't be or I
would, I would discourage people from reading it. I
told people when something really sucked, you know.
Yeah. But, but that's, that's a different, that's a
different kind of thing. But uh I wasn't thinking
perhaps uh so much as being offended, but perhaps
more as OK, so perhaps the guy here, the
creator went too far in terms of the, the
things graphically. And uh I mean, I don't think
I would feel well recommending the II, I was
able to go through it. I still think it's
a good story, but I wouldn't feel well recommending
this to anyone because even if the story is
good, I don't think that people would be particularly
enriched by being exposed to it. Something like that.
I, I can't, I can't come up with an
example of that. I mean, if, if, if I
felt that I don't remember, I don't remember the
story and I think I would probably, if I
felt so strongly about something I don't think so.
Have you like, is there a story that you've
read where you're like, wow, he, he or she
should not have gone there? That was too much?
Ok. So I'm going to explain to you what
happened here over the course of my life basically.
So probably until 10 years ago, I was one
of those people that was like, ok, so you
should be exposed to great art of, of any
kind. And it doesn't matter if it makes you
feel unwell, if it makes you feel a little
bit sick, even if it's good art, you should
be exposed to it. But then, um, for example,
uh I watched the anti-christ by Lars Von Drier.
I don't know if you ever watched that one.
Uh And I was like, I mean, it was
very hard to go through it, particularly the last
20 minutes or something like that. But I went
through it and I, I mean, I've never had
myself, uh, I, I was never exposed to any
story where I was like, ok, so I have
to stop here. I can't go further. I can't
take it anymore. That, that never happened to me
personally. But then I tried to show to watch
it together with a couple of friends from university
back then. And one of them accidentally accidentally skipped
the movie to one of the most violent scenes.
And they were like, man, I, I can, I
can, I can, I can't watch it. Sorry. Uh
Look, this is just too much and then the
same thing happened, uh when I tried to show,
for example, my mother, a couple of movies that
for this or that reason, she uh uh she
doesn't like the uh I mean, to see certain
kinds of things. And then, I mean, uh over
time I got to a point where I sort
of became more sensitive to the idea that perhaps
there are certain kinds of graphic things, perhaps not
so much in books, but in movies because you
actually see the stuff that that's happening there where
I, I mean, I, there are certain things that
I really hesitate to recommend to other people because
one thing that I think about now that I
didn't consider before 10 years ago or so is
OK, so this is a good story but is
it really worth it for someone to be exposed
to it? I mean, if someone is not and
never watches this, uh are they, would they be
missing on something, you know, and and, and now
I, and now I think like that and there,
and for example, the anti-christ is one of those
movies. Uh The adaptation of 120 Days of Sodom
by Pierre Paolo Paolini is another one of those
movies because of the sexual perversion and all of
that. Uh AND there are, there are perhaps a
couple more, I mean, it, the list is still
very small, at least the ones, the ones that
immediately come to mind. But now I have, uh,
uh, at least a small list of things that
look and unless people ask me directly about them,
I basically never mention them to anyone who is
not at least familiar with the existence of that
movie. For example.
II, I hear what you're saying. I, um, I
think probably in my case, um, I, I tend
to kind of do a pre emptive strike and
I, I will avoid something that is that I
just know I don't wanna see. Um, I mean,
a good example is, and I'm not, I'm really
not that big a horror fan but II, I
think my son probably would have watched this with,
would have enjoyed watching it with me. There's a
series called Saw. Yeah. Yeah. And it's that
I've, I've watched, I've watched the movie. I
know that's not for me. I've never seen a
single one of them so I'm not gonna judge
but I know that's not for me. But what's
really interesting to me is, for instance, you know,
I'm the movie The Exorcist. I mean, granted I
grew up Catholic, I went to Catholic schools, you
know, but the movie The Exorcist was so terrifying
to me when I was a kid that I
had nightmares about it into adulthood. I mean, well
into adulthood and my, you know, 16 year old
daughter who I think first saw the original Exorcist,
um, when she was a really little kid, all
three of my kids have seen it. They think
it's hilarious. I mean, hilarious. And they, they think
that part where she throws up the pea soup
is one of the funniest things they've ever seen.
They think the special effects are terrible. I mean,
the, that movie does not give them nightmares but
a little
bit. But wait a minute if they watched the
scary movies before watching The Exorcist because if they
did, because if they did it's easier to understand
why they would laugh because Scary Movie two is
all about
right with James Woods and, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I've
seen that. Exactly. Um, MAYBE, but I think also
they genuinely think it's a funny movie. I mean,
I think they genuinely think it's kind of like,
like when her head spins around, you know, that
was, that was so disturbing to me as a
kid to watch that. It was absolutely horrific and
to them they're like, that is so obviously not
real, you know, what I mean? And they just
think it's funny and, um, uh, so it, it,
it, I'm, I'm always intrigued by people who are
really into horror in this way and they don't
mind watching people get hacked to death and they
are completely able to separate, um, what they're watching
with real life, you know, and be like mom,
it's not real, don't you get it? It's not
real. And whereas to me I'm watching it and
I'm like, I know it's not real but it
feels real. You know, I can see it and
then I'm imagining this in my own life, but
not everybody feels that way and they're, they're able
to make that separation. I'm not one of those
people. I, uh, you know, it's why I'm not,
I mean, I love a great horror movie. I
mean, I think we've talked about this, that the
novel Dracula is one of my favorite novels of
all time. I think it's so good. Well, I
think the character is so good. Um, BUT I,
I, you know, I could not be one of
those people who loves horror and can watch saw
and, you know, uh, the conjuring and something, you
know, some other horrific thing back to back or
like those simulated snuff movies that I think that
is really horrific. To me, the idea, even if
it's, if it's acted out on film and it's
not real. And the idea of Snuff is, that's
probably where I would just wanna throw up. Yeah,
that makes sense. Now,
look, uh, horror, horror movies. Uh, IT, it, it
might be weird but, uh, even when it comes
to the list of movies that I don't recommend
to anyone, not one of them, apart from perhaps
the anti-christ, I'm not sure if it's classified as
a horror movie or not. But apart from that
one, there's not one single horror movie there. So
horror movies, I, I don't say that I'm a
horror movie fan. I've watched a ton of them
just because until, until a few years ago I
was addicted to movies. And so I've watched everything
out there, even the 19 eighties slasher movies, I've
watched all of them and most of them do
not bother me at all. Some of them make
me feel a little bit uneasy but not sick
nor anything like that. So, but, but I, I'm
not, I wouldn't say I'm a horror movie fan
but, uh, I, I mean, I guess that the
things that perhaps when it comes to recommending them
to other people bother me the most. It's when
it, it involves things that can actually happen realistically
in real life, you know, like, like for example,
what happens in the anti-christ that could happen in
real life, the sexual perversions in 120 days of
sodom and uh uh uh uh oh, have you
watched here Irreversible By Gaspar Noe with Monica Bellucci
uh yeah, so that movie involves uh a, a
very hard to go through rapes in, I mean,
that
would be, that would be difficult. I mean, I,
I would never go so far as to say,
you know, that, that it shouldn't be a movie
or anything like that, but there are definitely things
that I would avoid because to me they don't
have value
and, and for example, just a few minutes ago
I mentioned Tony. So I know and in the
Sopranos, there's also a rape scene. I don't know
if you remember this. But there's one episode where
his female therapist is uh leaving her office and
she's raped by a guy. I can't remember exactly
who the guy was. And I think that Tony
Soprano eventually gets across that and kills the guy.
Iii I can't remember. I can't remember exactly. But
uh I mean, uh that 10 of course, it's
always hard to watch those kinds of scenes. Always,
at least for me personally, it's always because I,
I feel my blood boiling because I get really
angry just imagining something like that happening in front
of me. And it really messes me up at
least for a few minutes. But that one actually,
I don't have any problem recommending the entire Sopranos
series to anyone even with that scene and with
other stuff, I don't have any problem at all,
but irreversible. I think that they just went too
far there. I mean, even I, myself, I watched
the movie once and I can't watch the movie
again ever again.
So I think probably for me what is, what
would be, uh, a line crosser is if a
movie was too nihilistic, um, and cease to have
any moral dimension because I think, I think our
lives have a moral dimension, you know, and, and
I, it's also just deeply disturbing to watch something
like that and be able to, um, uh, be
able to take any value from that and apply
it to my own life, which I think is
why I read and it's why I write. It's
why I watch movies. I mean, ultimately it's why
I consume art. It's to be, um, enriched in
some way. And if I don't find it enriching,
it's funny you should mention The Sopranos because I
too would recommend that series to anyone. But I
remember when I stopped watching it, um, and I,
I may have been pregnant at the time. It's
kind of funny because when I'm, when, whenever I
was, I was pregnant, there were certain things I
could not watch and I could not, I mean,
I just couldn't, I mean, I, I remember in
one of my pregnancies kill Bill came out, by
the way, I love Kill Bill. I watch it
now. You know what I mean? I couldn't watch
it. I mean, I couldn't, and, um, I remember
an episode of The Sopranos and I I have
not from that episode on, I, I never finished
the series. It was a young woman who was
a stripper at one of Tony's clubs and she
was pregnant with this awful guy's kid and he
beat her to death. Do you remember the scene?
That was so disturbing to me that, and I
knew that that guy was eventually gonna get it.
You know, there, there was a moral dimension to
the Sopranos actually. You know, but I, I'm pretty
sure I was pregnant when I watched that. Um,
BECAUSE I, I just couldn't, you know, I just
couldn't go beyond that. Um, AND not in a
judgmental way. I, I just couldn't watch it because
it, you know, it was so, uh, it was
disturbing to me on, on such a deep level.
Ok. So, II I made me
physically ill. I mean, I remember it made me
physically ill. Yeah.
OK. So perhaps, uh, 01 of the things that
bother me when it comes to how certain things
are sometimes depicted is if you really need to
do it that way or go that far because
for example, in the Sopranos, the rape scene, you
see some of it, but most of it is
suggested, you know, in irreversible, it's not suggested at
all.
I don't think
it's all there. And one thing that bothers me
about that, it's not just the morality of it,
but I, I, in, I wonder whether it's telling
me that perhaps the author, the director, the writer,
whoever is not that great at directing or writing
because for, for me, someone who's really good at,
uh for example, making, making someone feeling disgusted at
the rape scene does not have to show it
all the,
I agree. I, I, and I, and I, and
I think the level of
disgust and I think it, and I think someone
is a better writer if, uh for example, when
it comes to books or, I mean, there's that
idea of you show don't tell, right show don't
tell. In the case of movies, I would say
because it's all showing uh you show but not
too much. Are you sure? But you're not uh
describe, I mean, in, in that case, it's not
describing but it's showing uh everything down, down to
the details. Uh I
agree with that
and I, and I, and I think that perhaps
there are times that's just too much, it's not
needed. It's, it's just that's not needed to convey
the same kind of, or, or to create the
same kind of reaction in viewers or readers.
I would agree with that. I mean, it's funny,
I was talking about this with, um, with a
writer friend. Uh This is some time ago but
when uh I sat down to write um this
historical fantasy series, uh breath some years ago when
I started it, um you know, it has a,
a, a central love story to it. And at,
you know, at the time, and I think this
is largely still the case, really kind of explicit
love scenes had made their way into just about
every genre historical fiction. And, you know, it, it
had, you know, left the confines of erotica and
it was in science fiction, it was in historical
fiction, it was in, in pretty much every kind
of fiction. And I decided that I was not
gonna do that. I decided that I was gonna
have a very sensual love story and have it
be, um, you know, hopefully very emotional and very
compelling, but that I, that I was gonna have
a fade to black approach. And I'm glad I
did that because I'm, I'm for one, I'm really
sick of being bombarded by explicit love scenes at
this point. I feel like, um they're just there
because I don't know, maybe the writer feels like
they need to put it in there to attract
the reader's attention. Um And that we just keep
having to up the ante with these scenes and
with these stories because it's now it's just not
enough to have, you know, a passionate kiss or
even like, or, or even, you know, regular sort
of um sex that doesn't involve all sorts of
tricks. And after a certain point, it's like, really,
I, I mean, it, it's sort of like when,
you know, that the James Bond franchise has to
scale back, you know, like with the Roger Moore
ones when they started going to space and all
this stuff, it's like, no. Yeah. And they've kind
of got to bring it back to a place
where look, ok, now he's just using his fists
and his gun. He's not gonna be in space.
He's not gonna be doing anything, you know, we're
not going to be going to the paranormal. We're
not gonna make him do things that, that don't
in any way seem realistic for this, you know,
and now 56 year old man for God's sake
with bad knees probably. Um So I, you know,
that's, that's something that I, that, that I've come
to feel strongly about. I think that um I
think that the depiction of sex has just gotten
ridiculous, but in a lot of, a lot of
stories and not because I'm prudish about it. It's,
I'm not, it's just I'm bored by it, you
know, and, and I feel like we're constantly having
to add more whipped cream and more cherries and
more chocolate sauce and more peanut sprinkles and then
the colorful confetti sprinkles.
Yeah. No, but, but, but you know what, when
it comes to uh love scenes, sex scenes, whatever,
I mean, I don't have a particular problem uh
in the way they are graphically depicted in more
or less detail. I mean, perhaps sometimes I would
say, OK, so this is perhaps uh no longer
just a romance novel, this is perhaps already pornography
or something like that. But if people are into
pornography fine, I mean, I don't, I don't,
I don't have a moral problem with it in
that regard. I don't have, I'm not prudish about
it. But the, the thing, for example, about irreversible
and 120 days of sodom is that, I mean,
in 120 days of sodom, I mean, it involves
things that I wouldn't even mention here because this
will also be on youtube. And it's just too
much just to say that it's too much, even
for people that watch regular porn, it's just too
much
because it goes beyond gratuitous.
Yeah. And the, and then, and then adding, yeah,
and then adding the ribs in an irreversible, I
mean, sometimes I find myself asking, I mean, isn't
this wrong? I mean, and by wrong, I'm not
sure if I mean, morally wrong or artistically wrong
either because perhaps you shouldn't expose people to so
much graphic stuff because it, it feels sort of
wrong or because as an artist, you don't need
to go that far. And so perhaps you're not
as great an artist as you think you are
or as you could be. And, and, and another
thing that comes to mind and that when I
really straight out say that it's morally or was
morally wrong, for example, back in 20 I want
to say 2015, possibly 2016, there was an, an
art exposition in Germany or the Netherlands. I mean,
I, I might be getting the date and the
place wrong, but it was in definitely in Europe
and definitely in the mid 2010. So uh uh
someone uh put uh a dog in an art
exposition. He was, he was tied to the by
a rope, I think to, to the wall and
then uh uh in front of him. But uh
Alpa is rich. They put their uh a plate
with food and the dog couldn't reach the food.
And
I would, that would, that would infuriate me and
the,
and the, and the dog dive of starvation in
an art exposition. And when, when I, and, and,
and, and I, I mean, I didn't see that
directly. Fortunately, but when I got across that news,
I was like, man, whoever did this? I don't,
I don't care about abstract. I don't care about
abstract well sounding artistic liberty. That's just play
cruelty, cruelty.
I mean, you don't do and I,
I, you're right.
You don't do that to a living being full
stop it. I just stands there. I don't care
about artistic liberty and those well sounding abstract words,
I don't care about that.
I've never heard of that. And I'm, that's disgusting.
I just don't even, I don't even understand. I
don't think that's an artist. I think that's a
sadist who is pretending to be an artist. I
think that that's a very disturbed person because artists,
artists understand the difference between their work and you
know what I mean? They understand that it's pretend
and that they're, they're, they're reflecting parts of the
world around them and parts of their imagination. Um,
BUT that's, that doesn't make any sense to me.
I think that that artist was a sadist who
was masquerading as an artist. I don't think that's,
I don't, I, I don't even, I, I can't
even wrap my head around. I
know, look, there, there are, there are troubling stuff
in artistic creation but that one II, I mean,
that, that, that, that went beyond all limits for
me. That, that was just probably the worst thing
I ever heard an artist doing. Uh
Yes, I agree. I think, um I can't think
of anything in specific but I think that there,
that there have been times when I've been reading
something and I have felt uncomfortable because I feel
like the artist is either describing something that they've
done or want to do that is abhorrent. And
I can't say what makes me think that they're
not just that it's not just in service of
the story. I, I'm not really sure what it
is specifically that made me feel that except that
it's, it, it's similar to when you just get
a bad feeling about a person that you meet
and you just think, I don't, I don't like
that person. There's something about them and, you know,
we just had a very, you know, perfunctory conversation.
It's, there's nothing that I can point to specifically,
but I don't have a uh I don't have
a positive feeling about this person.
And, you know, I, I mentioned that example, that
example specifically because in that example, there's no doubt
that the guy who did that is an awful
but, but, but I mentioned
something, there's something very sick.
Yeah. But, but that's the point I wanted to
get at because sometimes I find myself suspecting if
there are particular kinds of creators, artists that, uh,
include certain things in their stories because they, uh,
uh, not because they just want to artistically explore
this or that, or create some sort of emotional
reaction but because they are actually sick in their
heads, I think, yes, I think for sure in
the same way that I think that there are,
you know, people go into certain professions that are
honorable professions but they go into those professions because
it allows them under, you know, the guise of,
of either, um, you know, working with Children or
being in law enforcement to act out certain fantasies
of theirs that are not so healthy. You know,
I, I, that's something that we always have to
be careful of when, um, you know, allowing people
to be a, in situations where others are vulnerable.
Mhm. Yeah. A and look, just to be clear,
I'm not saying at all at all that, all
artists are the mature, all artists are, are bad
people. I mean, one thing that at least I
learned in life and uh I haven't seen any
evidence that goes against it is that most people
are decent people. And that means that sometimes they
make mistakes, sometimes they do bad, bad things that,
but most of the time they're just going on
with their normal lives, they work, they have their
families, they do their things they try to do
as well as they can find. And then there
are a tiny minority of exceptionally good people and
then they are, there are also a t mi
uh, there's also a tiny minority of monsters and,
and, and, and, and, and, and that's also the
tiny minority of artists po possibly that I am
referring to here. So it's just that, that I'm
saying, I think
you're quite right and I, to me the evidence
for, for the fact that most people are, are
basically good under most circumstances, you know, particularly if
they're well socialized and if they're living within a,
a healthy enough society with uh, appropriate rules and
appropriate, um, punishments and, and, and, um, incentives. But
if, if that weren't the case, we'd all be
in pretty big trouble, you know, every time we
left our house, you know, it would be like,
like the movie the purge, right that my kids
have seen. Um, SO I, I think you're absolutely
right. I think though too, that, that tiny minority
can cause a lot of trouble, the tiny minority
of monsters. I mean, we can see that on
social media first. I mean, I think that there
are a lot of bots on social media. Um,
AND, well, that's, I guess an example of that
because here's somebody who's got a bot farm who
has, well, the worst intentions and are, you know,
dive bombing people's posts and saying absolutely horrible things,
anything from just, you know, things that are uh
abhorrent, just morally abhorrent to um racist or, you
know, whatever it is just to, to kind of
create the illusion that there are more people who
feel that way than, than there really are. So
that maybe they can feel less alone in their
depravity. I think that that is, you know, part
of the way that, um you know, a, a
platform like, like Twitter. Um BUT it's not just
Twitter. I mean, I don't mean to pick on
Twitter because I actually, I like Twitter. I use
Twitter, I use a lot of social media platforms
and I think that they can be a force
for a lot of good, but they can also
be this weird sort of fun house mirror. It's
funny, I saw this interesting, I, I passed this
interesting post the other day and I wish I
had saved it, but I think I can recall
it but they uh the, the post basically described
how certain social media platforms, um kind of cater
to a certain one of the seven deadly sins.
You know, Instagram is vanity. Uh I, I saw
that Twitter is wrath, right? Um, BUT I, I,
you know, Linkedin is Facebook is envy but I
tt is L
Yeah. Yeah, exactly. I, I thought that was really
smart because, um, you know, at their, at their
worst and this is, this is what's so hard.
I was talking to another friend of mine. She
had, you know, been, she had built out a
lot of um the Amazon's advertising console, you know,
system. Um YOU know, she, she worked in that
and as a result she uh you know, had,
had been to conferences and such where there were
people who were dealing with um you know, they
were iii I wouldn't say they were content moderators
but they had some sort of function within these
uh social media companies that, that had to, you
know, monitor bots and all of this. And she
was saying how just like God, I, I would
not want that job for anything else in the
world because it's so hard and you can't even
imagine all the crazy stuff that is happening. And
um you know, the bot farms and the, you
know, people who are, who are purposely, people and
entities who are, you know, purposely trying to um
mhm you know, change a narrative or, or make
us see ourselves or see the world in, in
this sort of fun house mirror way and, and
how do you manage that? How do you, um,
how do you get rid of the bots while
still allowing people to speak and allowing that free
flow of ideas to continue? It's very hard.
Yep. Yeah. But, but I mean, I just brought
this uh, discussion to the table about perhaps the
morality or immorality of certain, um, art pieces or
certain artists and, and perhaps uh possible the ontology
for artists or something like that because uh I
mean, I, I don't know, e even I myself
do not have any definitive answers to these questions.
And uh and I, and I myself am not
so sure even when it comes to that list,
I've mentioned of films, I don't recommend to anyone
if I should really not recommend them or I'm
still sort of thinking about it. And that's why
sometimes I bring that to the table when talking
with certain people to see if I can uh
figure out my own thought process. But uh I
mean, it's just questions that I think are worth
uh exploring because there are perhaps certain things that
perhaps we give artists too much leeway. Uh And,
and because they are artists, perhaps there are too
many things that we excuse and perhaps some of
them we shouldn't. I'm not sure.
Yeah, I'm not sure. II I tend to think
that when someone goes too far as the artist
with the dog did that, the way that we
tend to um counter that is with a society
healthy enough to condemn it and not reward it.
And that's, I think something that we really need
to be careful about in terms of um you
know, how, how we structure our lives, how we
structure our cultures and our societies and understanding um
when bad behaviors cannot be tolerated and must be,
um, must be not just openly discouraged but really
deterred in, in a way that, that benefits the
whole, right? But not in a way that, um,
iii, I guess causes of, of this feels unfair
and causes a reaction, you know, a, a counter
reaction. But it's, it's, it's hard. I mean, I,
I am not a moral relativist, you know, and
I think that the moral relativism that has kind
of gripped, um, that, that's, that we're in the
grips of, and that we have been in the
grips of for a few decades is not healthy.
I think that we have an obligation to ourselves
and to society at large and certainly to the
most vulnerable to make a decision as to what
is morally acceptable behavior and what isn't.
Yeah. And, and you know, and if we don't,
we put, we put people in danger, usually people
who are most vulnerable people who are poor people
who are, you know, Children who, you know, cannot
care for themselves and make decisions for themselves and
that, um, we have to have the strength to
stand up for, you know, what, what's, what is
the best thing to do even if, uh, it
can be harsh sometimes.
Yeah. No, I know. And, you know, another thing
that I find interesting here, at least for me
is that, um, I tend to fall much more
on the liberal side of the aisle when it
comes to politics, economics and all of that. But
when it comes to this particular artistic, moral questions
curiously enough, I, I guess that all of the
things I brought to the table here would be
the things that you usually associate with conservatives as
them, for example, saying that, oh, you shouldn't pick
that kind of thing in art and where, uh,
I mean, that, that sort of thing. But yeah,
it, it is what it is so. Well, we
need both. I mean, really we need, um, without
conservatives, uh, people who are more liberal and progressive
would take us off a cliff and without liberals
and progressives, conservatives wouldn't allow our society to grow
because too cautious, we need both to work together.
And I, I don't, I don't, I don't think
it would be healthy to be, um, someone who
only has a progressive mindset or only has a
conservative mindset. I think that, um, you know, part
of the culture war that we're having is the
result of these two extremes which often sound very
similar to one another. Um, HAVING arguments over the
vast majority of people who tend to pick and
choose their, um, their, their, well, their viewpoints, I
guess a little, a little more, um, bipartisanly, let's
put it that way. You know what I mean?
And you can be a very liberal person and
yet think, ok, I think that there are moral
limits to what, uh, say a performance artist like
the artist you mentioned should be able to do
that. No one should be able to come to
harm or no creature. Um No sentient creature like
a dog, you should be able to come to
harm because in the name of quote art, right?
I don't, I think that that is reasonable to
have that point of view and um just as
it's reasonable to be, you know, a conservative person
and, and say, I, I just, you know, don't,
don't have a problem with uh finding a compromise
on even an incredibly contentious uh societal issue like,
um like abortion or, or marriage rights or what,
whatever it is that that might be there, you
know, and I think most people are willing to
make compromises in between and most people understand that
there are pros and cons to, to most issues
and that we have to weigh those as, as,
as a society. And if we're, if we're not
weighing them and we're only kind of marching lockstep
with um whatever side we believe ourselves to be
on that, that doesn't really feel like progress either.
And that doesn't feel like, um, like it will
lead to a, a graceful and functioning society.
Well, actually, now that I think about it and
um referring to the, that example with the dog,
I think, I, I don't know exactly when that
started. But uh uh uh uh don't you see
now when many times in movies before the movie
starts, uh, when they evolve animals a message there,
something like no animals were, were hurt in the
filming of this movie or something like that. So
at least that's something that, uh, people care more
about and think that it goes beyond, uh, artistic
expression, I guess. Yeah, I
think, I think most people are, are horrified by
that. I mean, really, I mean, isn't that, that
the, the one of the signs of, of a
future serial killer, someone who tortures animals as a
kid? You know, I think that that is a
pretty serious taboo. Um, AND rightly so, uh, of,
you know, for one's own gratification to be hurting
another being, you know, that's, that's something that even,
you know, even with like, talking about 50 shades
of gray that there's a reason why in those,
in, in those, um, communities there are all sorts
of strictures that are put into place so that,
um, you never go too far because of how
dangerous it is. Um, WHEN we do go too
far. Yeah, it is dangerous. You know, I think
that.
Yeah, hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview.
Until the end. If you like what I'm doing,
please consider supporting the show on Patreon and paypal.
The links are in the description down below and
also please share like and hit the subscription button.
The show is brought to you by N Lights
learning and development. Then differently check their website at
N lights.com. I would also like to give a
thank you to my main patrons and papal supporters
per Larson, Jerry Muller and Frederick Sun Bernard Seche
Olaf, Alex Adam Castle Matthew Whittenberg, Arno of Tim
Hollowing, Eric Aleni John Connors Philip for Connolly. Then
the Metro Robert Winde INAs Yu Mar Nevs Colin
Holbrook, Simon Columbus Phil, Governor Mikel Stormer Samuel Andre
Francis for Agns Fergal cousin Hall, her Rag Michel,
Jonathan lebron Jars and Ka. Eric Heinz. Mi Smith
J We Hummel sad friends. David Sloan Wilson Yasi
de Ro NP, please. Nicole Barbaro, Adam Hunt Pablo
Stassi Alek Bach Ma he s of Zal Adrian
Yi Paulin John Bar, poso Julian Price Edward Hall,
Eden Bruner Douglas Fry Franco Beto Lotti Gabriel Cortez,
Orli Scott Zachary FTD and Smith John Wilman, Daniel
Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgio, Luke Lo the Chris
Williams and Peter Walla and David Williams the Costa
Anton Erickson Charles M Alex Show. Marie Martinez, Coral
Chevalier, Bangalore, Larry Dey Junior, Old Herring Starry Michael
Bay. Then spur by Robert Grassy. Zor and Jeff
mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Rads, Mark Kempel Thomas Dubner
and Luke Ni and re story Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Gilbert Jessica Nowicki Linda Brandon, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensley
Man. George Cort is Valentin Steinman, Paul Crawleys Kate
V Goer, Alexander Hubbard, Liam Dunn B. Masoud Ali
Mohammadi Perpendicular Jonas Herner. Slow. Good enough, Gregory Hastings
and David Pins of a special thanks to my
producers is our web, Jim Frank Lucas to Tom
Ween, Bernard Nic Ortiz Dixon Benedict Muller Thomas Trumble,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin Jarl Montenegro, Al Nick Ortiz
Nick Golden and Rosie and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergei Adrian and Bogdan K Yvette. Thank
you for all.